so guys let's go back to what you said
because i want to
take this a little more
do you believe that any woman in a
relationship should not have instagram
or are you saying that just women who
are in a relationship and are
posing in their bikinis or you know
doing any kind of a sultry sort of stuff
they're the ones that shouldn't have
instagram what do you think before he
answers
having instagram in a relationship yeah
i think i think i get i get what they're
saying because
it gives
it gives an outlet to cheat and it's
easier for
women to cheat through social media than
it is for a guy okay i think
so is that like she's for the streets it
depends what she's posting if she's like
posting her ass on socials yeah she's
she's for the streets yeah what about
you follow me on instagram yeah yeah
it's my instagram for the streets nah
nah i wouldn't say okay so that
instagram would be a green light yeah
okay okay
well if you're in a serious committed
relationship with a guy and you have you
know sexy photos of yourself on the
internet you know instagram is just one
medium that you can do it yeah it is
cheating
cheating like what about the guy is he
if he if he's in a relationship is he
allowed to have instagram yeah we're
different we're not in our undies
i don't think i was asking you i was
asking these guys
let me ask let me ask you a question are
men and women equal
yeah of course yeah no we're not at all
we're not okay uh men and women are
different
do you think men and women are equal
independent
[Laughter]
it depends what you mean by equal
yeah um
i think i think it's not about being
equal because we're never really going
to reach true equality anywhere i i
think it's more about
i think we need to spend more time
concentrating champion our differences
whether instead of making everyone
trying to be the exactly the same
because yeah not gonna yeah no i agree
actually i don't because i feel like in
any relationship there's always it's
never equal yeah like even in
friendships there's one leader one
follower exactly like it's not
nothing's equal
um but
i kind of feel the same way about guys
with
shirtless selfies
fair like if a guy has a bunch of
shirtless selfies i kind of look at i
kind of look at you funny it's
unnecessary especially like
unless you're like a fitness influencer
or something i don't see any reason why
you're all
yeah i just don't see any reason why
your shirt should be off yeah but i do
think it's different though because
a girl's ass like dudes are gonna like
be like oh my god but like a guy's
shirtless selfie like i just it's not
the same effect i don't know
i'd be like oh that's nice but not
yeah maybe i think there's like a small
percentage of guys that will literally
have girls thirsting over them but
that's like like one percent of like
so yeah
most of me it's like a dad
like i put that away
put that
yes we're different of course we're
different but you know were you talking
about pay parity what are you talking
about when it comes to being different
well the definition of equality is being
the same in quantity size degree or
value and nothing between us is equal
we're very different what i mean by
don't think we are of equal value
uh well here's the thing from a human's
rights perspective and you know the
value of your life yes we're equal no
one is better than anyone in that regard
but when it comes to biology and
intersexual dynamics we're 100 percent
different and the reason why that is
true scientifically that he's he's
correct we are different right but
what i don't understand is how does that
apply to the question that i asked when
i said
okay so the reason why is because we
have differing sexual strategies men
want quantity women want quality so
our sexual strategies are literally
opposing each other so men want to be
able to get with as many girls as
possible right unlimited sexuality shout
outs our guy rolex monster we talk about
this in detail versus women i say women
want typically unlimited security from
the best man that they can get versus
men want to get the most women they can
get so it
you think that's true
to an extent yeah to an extent i think i
think
at a certain point that stops
just because it's long dealing with like
multiple girls all the time it's just
it's long it's effort it's like too much
work yes it's like a part-time job it's
just
it's a part-time job explain it's in
great detail
just to have like it's just like
spinning multiple plates and having to
talk to a lot of people and then and
it's expensive
okay
that's the main it's an actual
investment so
he's not wrong but at the same time
there comes a point where
you just can't be bothered anymore no i
um i agree for the girls because it's
not like like girls have so many
requirements
to like be with them you know what i
mean yeah like even even me like i could
think of five things off the top of my
head a guy has to have
a girl
five things uh five
close to my height or taller okay um
he has to he can't be super loved
okay
the guys that are like male feminists
you're talking to the wrong [ __ ] you're
talking to the wrong
not
me that's like nothing makes me want to
end a date sooner
i don't i don't i just don't understand
i just don't i don't think you can be a
male feminist
you kind of have the vibe who you me
just because of the glasses i always
assumed
[Laughter]
i was hoping
just to clarify guys i'm not a male
feminist
i might get the wrong person
but
or i can't do i can't do bombs either
okay so like but dude doesn't it's okay
if you're starting a business or
something but man's just sitting around
all day doing nothing
yeah so
or um
i don't know i can i can i'm not gonna
go on but
but like you you get the idea there's
like a list of requirements where like
and then it just seems like it's more
like hot and there
yeah
[Laughter]
pretty much really willing
i feel like we're yeah we're more visual
yeah yeah as as guys that's that's
that's the first thing that
we look for straight away and then
everything else comes second if it does
come into it at all question yeah
for me there could be a guy that's like
super good looking very attractive to
you but if he opens his mouth
and says the wrong thing it's like gone
can girls do the same thing 100 however
you're still smashed
like you'd be like you'll just be like
shh
maybe like like from behind
like you could like hear her talk less
she'll crop my airpods in and just have
music played
yeah yeah no um it can't happen the
other way but like i said
the difference is a guy will stick a guy
will feel that way
and then still smash right
yeah and
i think
that's why you see girls that like hate
men
and i've always like the girls that hate
men a lot they've always been ran
through because why else you hate men
if you don't preach if you don't deal
with a lot of men
it's either it's either they've they've
been run through or they're bitter
because they don't get attention
oh it's
like
the whales yeah yeah
it's been that way it's the beginning of
time powerful and strong men have had
hordes of women and then women align
themselves with the strongest men so we
don't play by the same set of rules and
our sexual strategies influences how we
view the world how we view the opposite
gender how we uh try to uh procreate
with each other we're very different so
what's what men can do
women can't necessarily do sometimes so
we're not the same
and it's just unfortunate
that that does not benefit women for
once
sorry so just going back to that
question that i asked can a man be on
instagram
in a relationship yes but not a woman
it's it's not the same
why does it depend on the content that
they're putting out if i'm shirtless on
instagram like
showing me big fat man boobs and
gyrating around sir put those away
[Music]
i'm sorry to help you
sexy dance
that would be cheap what if i was just
on there talking about you know fitness
apps and stuff that's a whole different
vibe so it's content related right yeah
but the thing is is that i don't think
people understand this that a man that's
one
even a man that's extremely good looking
is not gonna get nearly the amount of
options that a woman that's mediocre
no that is so not true
do you know how many hot guys get dm'd
on instagram oh we're not talking about
dms we're talking about real life
benefits it's like no you're going to be
served first at the shop and stuff like
that i'm talking about instagram you're
saying a man can go on instagram in a
relationship and it not because
so okay um i'm gonna get one of my guys
to show you guys something but yes a lot
of women are unaware of this but men
unless they're in the top
two percent of looks and aesthetics and
everything else like that they get
virtually no play in online dating sites
instagram men don't get as much sexual
attention as women think yeah that's so
true and i was actually i was at work
drinks um a few days ago and we're just
talking about dating apps and literally
one of the guys was like guys i've been
on dating apps for two years and i've
never got a like
yet like it's and to me i was i was
shocked i was like wait what but it's
what you're saying is real there's a
whole
the majority of guys
don't get attention like that
do you have girls dm you from your show
[Laughter]
yeah sometimes like how many how every
day
oh no no no every every week
like once a week
twice a week
about once a week maybe once a week so
you'll get like four dms from girls a
month
yeah but yeah yeah pretty much out of
the four how many how many would you
like
the quality decent oh yeah yeah quality
if the quality
there are some times where i get i feel
insulted when someone that isn't of
quality slides in and i'm like
is this my level
let me show you this is like oh my god
it like doesn't end
oh snap
like that's not even the hidden
like it doesn't
but to be fair most of these people like
let me show you
like what am i gonna do with that
oh oh come on oh no but that's like 90
percent of them dude
he looks about 5'4
no that's what i mean like but you like
like
because i i know what he's saying and
girls will get a lot of dms but they're
always from weird guys that don't have
profile pictures
so it's like
like yeah you get a lot of attention but
it's not from the guys you you want half
the time
yeah yeah like so
it's not like i'm tempted to like call
up jose sorry jose
give jose a chance jose deserves some
play
i do understand what he's saying though
so but i do think
i don't know i'm really unattracted to
guys that do this shirtless selfie thing
too yeah yeah yeah
no
what are you thinking
i'm not sure yeah i'm not sure i'm just
okay well we'll keep going yeah the
issue is that women see the world
through their view they think i get a
lot of attention so attractive guys must
be getting a lot of attention too and
that couldn't be further from the truth
men do not get nearly the same amount of
uh sexual attacks they're still getting
it so i don't know
not as much as like you know there's a
lot of things
because a girl might get say let's say
50 dms that are have guys wanting to
date her when the guy gets 20 dms yes
there might be a little difference there
but they're still getting hit on by yeah
but okay but the difference is out of
the 50 there's maybe one or two you'd
consider and the guy would consider all
20. guys don't
but what she's missing the point in the
fact that yeah
we make the first move yeah that's true
that is true it's harder for guys i'm
not even gonna yeah i'm not gonna argue
like girls don't really they don't
always they don't always slide into your
dms like they'll they might like a few
pictures they might
they'll they'll drop the handkerchief
yeah to give you the signal to move in
but
most of the time it's going to be us so
what's she talking about
you can't compare you can't she's
irritating me now
this is this is true it's it's
definitely harder for guys to like yeah
i i agree i agree
let's go back to the old night club the
rules let's go back to the nightclub if
you're at the nightclub and the boys
have talked about this on the fresh and
fit podcast
boys will line up and we'll stand there
for all right let me show you something
real quick i'm gonna show you guys
something real quick oh wow
this is so interesting right here we
have uh a chart from okay cupid and this
illustrates that even the most
attractive men in the light blue
are not even complete are barely
competing against girls in the mid-range
average girls not even half not even
half the last
not even half of the messages
now that's on a dating site on instagram
this is even more pronounced
okay and this doesn't account for you
know okay so you see the
you see this is the the females and
that's how attractive they are on like
this scale so it's saying that the even
average girls get more dms than the
hottest guys
but who are we getting the dms from
yeah
like
with those guys
i
no it's still harder
it's still harder for guys it's just
wild
you're telling me the most attractive
guys
are still less than an average
huh
yeah because
like
even on off right yeah the most
successful girls aren't the hottest ones
they're the ones that like this the the
simps think they can attain
ah
so like the girls that are like sixes
and sevens do better because the simps
like think they can get them in their
head that is why so then they'll get
more yeah so they make more money a lot
of the times
oh god man we need to do better man
what are you guys doing
the plenty of fish data the tender data
that we have
men do not get nearly as many options as
women and even if we're talking about
top tier guys they still cannot compete
men and women are not the same we're not
blank slate equals
they're not the same
let me finish please
it's nice it's not making you you're not
actually proving your point very well i
literally have a chart on the screen
proving that women get far more
attention than men do you want from the
dating site that says women get more
attention yes that's obvious but the
point you made was that women should not
be allowed on instagram if they're in a
relationship because of the attention
they get and you're kind of saying that
guys can so question for you if you're
dating somebody right you shouldn't be
on dating i'm sorry i can't take fresh
serious
that's god's taking serious whatever
your thoughts
he's got a big chain though oh yeah
overcompensating
um
no um
yeah this is this is wild but however
this this woman's backtracking a lot
she like she'll she'll go to make a
point and then myron will cancel out her
point and then she'll pretend like she
didn't make the point they always women
always do that and it's really like
watching this
it's weird being because
i've experienced it being in a situation
but it's weird to be outside and look
and actually see it happening from the
outside yeah it's wild well and
like he just he he actually did a good
job disproving your point he's like a
chart ready to go he's doing well so far
he's yeah he's prepared yeah i'll type
myron
not on a dating app no okay perfect so
do you know right instagram is one of
the biggest data apps in the world
yeah i get that but it's also it's also
insane where people like to share other
things it's not all just thirst traps
right
so you know every if you're if you're in
a relationship not every girl is posting
a picture of herself in a bikini here's
a problem
if there's two scenarios here right you
guys like not the girls i follow
if you see my feet
it's like they're not
the girls are i don't know
i post a picture of himself let's say
abs shirtless right he gets his kitchen
agrippa's picture our story our pulse
right oh my god do they have a dog
that's new
oh my god
okay that's so cute
the problem is that like attention is
way out skilled and it's gonna be sexual
because off rip what do guys want they
want to look at pictures and take a shot
of the girl that that's it girls man oh
he's cute he's handsome but no no
they're not gonna really approach him
like oh i want you it's like okay cute
hard eyes and that's it girls are gonna
go after it like in a different way
we're saying and also we're specifying
that when she has sexy photos of herself
on the internet and she's in a
relationship that is cheating that is
disrespectful to the man it's not that
he's the guy what is it
i agree with that i think that you
shouldn't post those traps
100 i think that's disrespectful if if
if your girl's posting first traps
that's not your girl that that is that
is no she's everyone's girl
for the streets like advertising hundred
percent
yeah it's just it's just why i've always
said like why why
if i
being your partner should come with
certain benefits
why do i have to do all the work but
everyone gets the also gets to benefit
you know i mean like
i pay for spot five premium i'll be
pissed if if people on the free plan
were getting what i was getting
i'll be pissed
the shirtless top and he's in a
relationship is that cheating no no
because it's not the same at all
[Music]
this guy's talking about himself
he's like
i know a lot about this
i know i could tell you what we do this
is his whole bag
i was just doing it yesterday
oh my gosh no he is he's
sometimes he he's drive snitching
himself right now
i wonder if his wife is watching
me let me let me break this down for
y'all okay so let's let's let's uh
uh jackie's let me let me ask you a
question what is your dream car
my dream car yes your dream car
oh i'm not she could have any car she
wants yeah what's the dream car what are
you what are you what are you doing i'm
probably driving i'm driving range rover
i love it so let's just say i've already
got it let's go let's go into a scenario
here okay
that's not us playing these centerpieces
here all right and just let me finish
let me finish this concept guys let me
let me get through it okay okay so let's
say you go to the uh to the dealership
and you buy a brand new range rover okay
range rover sport you've been wanting it
for a while fully decked out
hundred thousand dollars right australia
120 120 000 australian right 300 here we
got the luxury car tax you don't know
300k 300k right so yeah you drive it off
you you know you shake hands with the
car dealer
sign the paperwork
pay the money buy it cash you're good to
go drive it off the lot you don't care
about it losing value whatever this is
your dream car take it back to your
house
two weeks later
okay
the uh the car dealer comes back to your
place says hey listen man
we're kind of showing on cars uh we're
gonna need to put a for sale sign on
your car and a couple days a week we're
gonna just need to put on display back
at the dealership and you know one or
two people might test drive it are you
okay with that how would that make you
feel
i know the analogy you're trying to make
i own that car i don't own my partner in
a relationship though i don't own them
again answer the question how would that
make you feel well obviously i wouldn't
be okay with that okay thank you that's
exactly how men feel when their women
post sexy photos of themselves on the
internet to advertise to other men
because women men are territorial with
their women it's been that way since the
beginning of time you don't own us in a
relationship so we can post okay but
it's not you of course you can do what
you want yes but he's just going to
leave you after exactly like she's
totally missing the point it's not about
controlling it's about if you're doing
that you're just not going to find
someone that's going to stick around
yeah that's which that's literally not a
guy with a backbone anyway yeah there's
a lot of guys that'll stick her out but
not and those weird guys that are like
kind of into it
i like
get off on like i don't know i don't
know anyway
well the other thing i i understand like
where she's coming from because i think
she what she's trying to say is like
there's certain guys that are so
controlling with like everything
and they just want to control everything
but i don't think it's controlling to
say don't post your ass on the internet
when you're dating you shouldn't even
have to say don't push yourself you
shouldn't be very scared
i always think about the internet's
gonna be around forever right yeah and
i'm gonna i'm gonna have like kids
hopefully you know
and and like grandkids and they're just
gonna go on the internet one day and be
like oh that's oh grandma oh yeah yeah i
tried my rule is like if i had a kid
would i want them seeing this but a lot
of girls don't really follow that rule
that's like that whole thing that
happened with kim kardashian recently
when um was it saint when it was on a
random game online and then just saw
sort out for the tape